hello everyone and welcome back to the
singfield cup it is the penultimate
round and it is one of the bloodiest
rounds in a top tournament Fabi has ever
seen and this game is no exception it's
already versus Wesley so and it's quite
a quite a nice nice game uh before we
check it out there is a statement that
was made by the chief Arbiter of the
sinful cup regarding what's been
happening uh in in the past few days
regarding the the biggest scandal in
chess history uh and this is um uh this
is oops this is the statement so uh the
2022 single cup Chief Arbiters statement
uh Saint Louis September blah blah in
response uh to the recent rumor
circulating the Chess World I can
confirm that we currently have no
indication that any player has been
playing unfairly in the 2022 singfield
cup that includes all rounds uh place to
date we have been running all the grand
Chester events including the single cup
and other major tournaments here in
Saint Louis for many years with the same
strict anti-cheating measures that were
in place for rounds one to three and
we're not aware of any Fair uh play
violations during these past events
these measures included scanning of
players with metal detectors prior to
games and randomly after games close
observation of the players and fair play
analysis by Professor Kenneth Reagan
using the fide game screening tool
however on behalf of all the players and
the event I consulted the grand Chester
Chief Arbiter David Sedgwick and
together we had we advocated that
additional anti-cheating measures be
enacted after round three these measures
included the scanning of players with RF
scanners and the 15-minute delay on the
live broadcast I'm very thankful to the
organizers in Saint Louis who
immediately agreed to these requests
despite additional expenses last minute
technical issues and the loss of a truly
live broadcast the Arbiter team will
continue to remain Vigilant and all of
the anti-cheating measures that have
been in place will continue to be so for
the remainder of the event yeah Chief
Arbiter Chris bird so that's uh
basically uh what what we have there is
nothing new on the on the topic uh and
uh as soon as soon as there will be I
will keep you guys informed so let's get
to the game algresa has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 uh we have E5 by
Wesley Knight F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop
to C4 alireza goes for the Italian game
with Bishop to C5 The Joker piano and
now Pawn to D3 uh we have Knight to F6
uh castles and now D6 with C3 and the
Wesley also castles we have h3h6 and now
Rook the E1 so all very standard moves
of the uh jacobianism we have A6 A4 now
preparing B4 uh so Pawn to A5 uh Wesley
says Nope you will not be playing B for
this game so okay Knight beat the D2 and
now Bishop to E6 and this is where
uh things start to get very very
interesting we have Pawn to B3 by
alireza and now comes Rook to E8 uh here
there is a game even where Bishop
captures and C4 was played um Alexander
grishuk defeated Juma Vive with with
this idea uh but Rook to E8 is is much
more common uh so Rook to E8 or rather
Bishop Bishop to B5 uh and also Knight
to F1 those are the top moves um uh Rook
to E8 not so much uh and here we have
Bishop to B2 and this is now a new move
so already as of move 12 we have a
completely new game uh in this position
I meant that Knight to F1 and Bishop to
B5 are known moves uh but Bishop to B2
has never been played before so now we
have a completely new game so as alireza
allowed it a Wesley of course executes
D5 immediately and we have Bishop to B5
and the D captures an E4 we have D
captures and now Knight the H5 uh trying
to get the Knight to that a very active
F4 square but also just keeping it on H5
is also fine it's at some point you
might bring it to G3 uh DF Pawn spin so
the F1 will not be able to move we have
knighted the C for biologists and there
are you really don't have any good
discoveries here like if you try
something like Knight captures on E5
with the idea of capturing the Knight
the just Knight characters on E5 and now
of course if Queen captures there's
Queen captures on D2 so the tactics
don't work in in White's favor so here
Knights the C4 putting more pressure on
that E5 pawn and now we have Queen to F6
uh of course Wesley is trying to get
something out of this uh F2 Pawn as the
bishop is beautifully placed here so
Bishop captures valid as a b captures on
C6 and now Knight C captures on E5 and
interestingly uh it's only move 17 but
alireza's position is completely lost
yeah but you have to you have to play it
uh to absolute perfection to term to
pull this off and in the game that was
not the case uh here we still played
Bishop captures on H3 which is a
spectacular move uh and a very strong
one but there is an even stronger one
and I will show it so Bishop captures an
H3 yes however with the inclusion of
Rook 8 to d8 with Rook 8 to d8 attacking
the queen and only now after the queen
moves do you go for this bishop captures
an H3 idea because then it's a much
different story Bishop captures some H3
uh of course you can you can never
capture this if you if you capture you
just get destroyed Rook captures on E5
and so on Rook captures for example
Knight captures Queen captures uh and uh
well that's just it the bishop The Rook
coming into the attack the Knight it's
uh it's it's too overwhelming to play
this so basically what you would try is
C4 open up the the dark Square bishop
and now Queen to F4 again uh not all
that much to do the queen is coming to
G3 and after King the H1 on pinning from
this plan just root captures on E5
Bishop captures on E5 and now Bishop
captures and G2 with check after King
captures Queen to G4 check King to H2
and now you can play uh a lot of moves
about Bishop to D6 is the is the most
precise one so this is how uh how Wesley
could have defeated alireza for example
Bishop captures Rook captures Now The
Rook is also coming to G6 uh the Knight
is hanging and if you if you defend the
Knight then let's say Knight to F4 now
this is being threatened this is being
threatened uh if Knights they want to
guard the G2 and H3 squares now Rook to
G6 now this is being threatened uh and
after Rook to G3 of course just Queen H5
check King G1 and not Knight the E2 with
check King F1 and Knight D4 so uh very
very nicely done and now of course white
resides as the queen is hanging and also
if you move the queen then uh Queen to
H1 will result in Checkmate even if you
trade Rooks doesn't really matter the
threat Remains the the A2 square is
taken on
uh by the by the night so once the queen
moves of course Queen to each one will
be Checkmate so this is only one line
that I decided to show you it's a fun
line uh but yes uh Wesley's idea only uh
if he threw in a nice Rook 8 to d8 first
but okay Bishop captures on H3 also very
strong but now uh now uh alireza can
just bring the Knight back to D3 this uh
does not allow Rook to D to come with an
attack on the queen also it attacks the
bishop also it adds a Defender to the F2
pawn and still Rook 8 to d8 is the best
way for Wesley to continue and he should
do this but then Knight D4 and uh well
it's it's a very very very unclear uh so
instead after this Knight the D3 move uh
Wesley doesn't like the idea of Rook 8
to d8 he plays Queen to G6 which also
makes perfect sense he wants to deliver
Checkmate here but it's very easy to
Parry this threat so here at night the
H4 attacks the queen also Knights guards
against Checkmate Queen 5 now attacks
the Knight and now Knight captures on C5
and this is uh one very very important
attacker that was just eliminated Queen
captures on H4 and now G captures an H3
and here Wesley plays Queen to G5 with
check he has to pick up the Knight
somehow again maybe a trickier way to go
about it is Rook to E5 just put more
pressure on the Knight and also prepare
Rook to G5 check but he decides to go
for Queen to G5 check we have Queen to
G4 alireza offers a queen trade and of
course now Wesley just picks up the
piece so a queen captures on C5 we have
C4 now all it is a putting pressure on
G7 for the moment the Knight is
defending it so it's not a problem and
now Rook 8 to B8 by Wesley and here uh
this is the well uh again Rook to d8
could have been played that there are
some moves that uh maybe uh are uh or
maybe just better like Queen to G5 for
example uh but uh after Rook 8 to V8
there is a beautiful beautiful move that
already is a place uh and that is Ponte
E5 and once you see it now it all makes
sense uh as the Knight on H5 is hanging
so how do you deal with this uh you
could also just play Rook captures on B3
it's possible uh but uh it's uh it's uh
it's extremely complicated for example
if Rook captures on B3 uh you don't go
after the Knight the point is there's
Bishop to D4 attacks the queen and now
once the queen moves Now You're Gonna
Play Bishop to E3 uh as if you capture
the Knight then your Bishop Hank so
Bishop to E3 and now the point is the
Knight has nowhere to go you can't
really save the Knight so once you trade
let's say queen capture spawn captures
again the knight uh uh has nowhere to go
it doesn't matter if the Queens get
traded off or not uh White will just be
better here but still it's very unclear
through capture 75g captures uh this is
a weak Pawn this is a weak Pawn so uh
yes alireza would be upper Bishop but
those are six pawns uh Wesley has so uh
if anyone can win this it's white but it
would not be very very clear but here
Wesley played the G6 uh instead he just
defended his Knight and now there is a
big problem there is a move out it is a
complete where he will be completely
winning so feel free to pause the video
and try to win this game for alireza uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh taking away
almost all the squares from the black
queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Bishop to A3
that's the that's the good stuff uh now
the the queen can't go here can't go
here you can go up the board you can go
to E7 but again the bishop will take it
so you can only go to B6 or to A7 and uh
neither is uh is all that great Queen to
B6 was played in the game but now comes
Pawn to E6 and now you see why G6 wasn't
the the greatest of ideas uh as it it
just weakens the black Ink's position
too much and of course the E6 Pawn now
completely undermines a black structure
here so here Wesley tries C5 this will
allow the queen to somewhat help out
with the defense the defense but it is
not enough captures with check on F7
King captures on F7 Queen to D7 with
check with King to f8 and now we have
Queen to D5
uh just threatening Bishop captures and
C5 which would uh win the queen uh so
King to G7 and now Bishop characters and
C5 and here uh if you move the queen and
again there really aren't all that uh
many great squares like for example you
go Queen F6 like Bishop here just uh
loses material for black if you go let's
say Quinta A6 again just Rook capture 78
Rook captures Queen D7 check picks up
the rook and black gets checkmated very
quickly so instead we have Knight to F6
attacking uh alireza's Queen but here
alireza just trades because of course
the end game is completely winning for
him he plays Bishop captures on B6 with
Knight captures on D5 and here Rook
captures an E8 we have Rook campus 98
and now uh Bishop captures on A5 uh I'm
just gonna check something real quickly
now I think the the game uh might have
ended even even sooner than this uh yeah
okay the the game uh didn't go for
Bishop captures on A5 as soon as a rook
capture 78 was played it was actually in
this position that Wesley so resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here obviously uh the move that
I've shown are are the reason why uh so
what do you do uh the the Knight here is
hanging The Rook is hanging you can
maybe take the bishop but then you lose
the Rook if you if you play in for
example Knight captures here then we'll
capture some B8 again it's not not much
better uh and if you go for the for the
standard Rook captures and an E8 ninjas
Bishop captures on A5 and again uh there
there's now while it has too many pawns
uh also the Knight is saying once you
move the Knight you can play some like
rookie one you offer a rook trade of
course a rook trade would be winning for
white so you can move the Rook but then
rookie 7 checking F6 row captures here
and just a weightless position
completely falls apart uh so yeah uh
that was not seen on the board after
this uh Rook capture 78 move uh it was
in this position and with 32 that Wesley
so resigned the game and alireza takes a
great great Victory uh so even though
you can see that um maybe oh okay it's
hard to maybe say it but uh
uh Bishop captures on H3 is a is is an
incredibly strong move but Rook 838
isn't even a stronger one so for example
in your own games if you have a position
if you find a really really great move
you know it doesn't hurt to double check
if there's an even better one maybe
maybe lurking around the corner uh so
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank uh Paul certain
which csfi ravishing reptiles YouTube
another casual encoder and David Kimura
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the zingfield cup until it
finishes uh I think I I left around six
uh on my interface when in fact this is
round eight yeah that's really weird uh
six is very similar to eight but uh yeah
good thing I caught it at least for for
the end of the video but yeah this is
round eight there we go alright that's
updated uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day